but yeah why did you decide to start
doing a podcast after the site was going
people were asking for it it seemed it
seemed like a good idea I mean the
number of people who asked me to do a
podcast was so much higher than people
who asked or any other feature and also
I think you know part of the text
interviews was that you have to share
your revenue so everyone is completely
transparent and the number of people
that I reached out to you it with dot
would have really good stories for the
site that people can learn from who were
willing to share everything but their
revenue was like pretty high and so I
kept tired getting tired of people
saying you know I'm not gonna come on if
I have to share my revenue you need some
other way or I can come on share my
story so the podcast kind of you know
helped me to kill that bird and also you
know it appeased people who wanted me to
do a podcast but I was terrified of it
because like I said earlier like I don't
I've never done a podcast is it were
there people you admired at the time
you're like I want to make a podcast
like X yeah I was just like you know
what I'll try this I had a very like
lazy approach to I'm not gonna do a ton
of research I'm not going to I'm just
gonna try talking to people and see how
it comes out and have my own style I
think it's worked out I've gotten better
over time
yeah well what are you what are the
skills you've developed you think I
think I've gotten a lot better at
preparing efficiently I like reading
there Oh knowing what to read and what
to listen to you what kinds of questions
to ask
that'll be engaging and that they'll
give good answers to and how to follow
up on the question if you get an
unexpected answer some kind of a control
freak I'm like okay here's exactly
what's in the beginning you know I'm
gonna ask question ABCDEF and this is
how it's gonna go and like you know you
ask the question they start giving your
answers all over the map and suddenly
your perfect plan is started to disarray
so I think just like having the
composure and the ability to calm down
and be like okay it's okay
just listen what they're saying and have
a normal conversation was difficult at
first
other things like I don't know if you'd
call this a skill but just being
comfortable like in my own skin like not
not cringing at the sound of my own
voice because you got at your own yeah I
don't know podcast but yeah I mean I
would go back and listen it's like I
don't know like if you hate the sound of
my first now I'm fine with it but it
versa
I sound awful like who's gonna listen to
me now it's not a problem yeah you can
only spend so much of your time
cringing at yourself
I mean like the amount of hours I've
seen myself on video and listen to
myself on a pod cage whatever he gave
it's fine yeah like yeah that is one of
the things that I I thought the fear
would remain and it completely goes away
maybe to a fault but yeah the video
element has thrown a few people what um
what was your favorite episode I haven't
listened all album yet it's hard to say
if they do more is like I'm gonna hurt
somebody's feelings okay and then I
forget to you know what happened in that
episode but some of the coolest ones I
don't know what my friend Julian Shapiro
who's got a growth consultancy called
bell-curve
and he just like deep dive and they're
like a bunch of different kind of
stories of him working with different
clients and he was not afraid to share
like times what he just messed up so I
thought that was really cool hmm I
really like the episode I did last week
with West's boss that was a good one
yeah he's a great guy I mean he's gets
an enormous amount of work done to be
just a one person he's got an email it's
like 170 thousand developers on it that
he's built by himself in like five or
six years Twitter following about
hundred thousand people and he's just
trucking along
he works 9:00 to 5:00 puts his laptop
down and then goes to hang out with his
wife and his kids he's got it together I
wondered about that like is there a list
of people that you admire man that that
person has it figured out like I want to
do exactly what they're doing yeah
there's a lot of people and it's like I
always forget I'm like man that person's
got it figured out in the next week I've
totally forgotten about it moved on to
other things yeah what's boss guy your
looks pretty good yeah it's okay i I've
seen a handful of like roundups of indie
hacker pro tips from every episode are
you continuously integrating their great
ideas into your daily life or do you
kind of just go your own way yeah I
think it's funny it's one of the things
I was telling a friend a couple of days
ago I think generally speaking like all
of us tend to overweight like novel
advice like things that are new or
flashy or we haven't heard before and we
tend it's like so easy to ignore the
thing so we hear all the time you know
like oh make something people want talk
to your customers exercise yeah yeah
exercise take some time off like
heard that before I get it yeah but I
try to have the discipline that when I
see that kind of repeated advice to take
it to heart and not look at it as as
something that okay you know to have I
heard this before yes it doesn't matter
but more you know as a reminder to
myself like am I actually living by this
you know I have internalized this
alright like to think I have it like am
I actually talking to my customers am I
actually taking time off am i actually
exercising and the answer a lot of times
just no so I think when people do like
these roundups and people analyze things
and I see this advice repeated I take
the time to ask myself of him doing it
and you know I thing I've gotten better
at it just repeated reminders to myself
yeah I think you become conscious of it
but I agree I don't need 12 new morning
routines it's a we we posted a bunch of
question or other people posted
questions to Twitter for you you have a
lot of fans online
Ryan Hoover producthunt asked what do
you believe that most others do not
shrink acquired this one
yeah and glad I got this question on
Twitter rather than just being asked
randomly cuz it's hard to answer unless
you've thought about it yeah kind of a
funny story so I think this question
originally comes from Peter teal who
would ask the founders of companies that
he was interested in investing in just
as a way to find out if like what
they're doing is truly unique and
whether they'd be able to have like a
monopoly and very few competitors that's
why he liked it I liked it when I heard
it because it's kind of a sneaky way to
get somebody to say something
controversial yep so when I was in YC
five years ago I asked Paul Graham
that's like I think 2011 I was like hey
PG you know what do you believe the guy
asked what do you believe that other
smart people don't and it took him a
long time to answer he was just like I
don't know my thoughts they're not
indexed that way but any ended up coming
up with an answer and it worked it was
controversial like I don't think anybody
would very many people would agree okay
I can't say what it was
I can respect for him I don't mean to be
a tease but luckily I've had some time
to think about it's a probably the most
obvious one is I think that it's
probably a bad bet to start a VC funded
company for the vast majority of people
you should not go that route but there's
other things that I believe to you I
think that and the value of kind of this
culture of always talking about like you
know what mission drives you and we kind
of are not honest about the fact that a
lot of us are motivated by money and
financial things I think it's probably
better for the world if people can just
be upfront and honest about that I think
I got a few others but let's start with
those to you yeah no I completely agree
and I think your or everyone's ability
to rationalize is unbelievably powerful
yeah and you can be into anything and if
you're good at it like just being good
at the game is often enough to drive
people so you see like folks criticizing
you know anyone who works in anything
and they're like why do they care about
this why do they do that no it's because
they're really good at it yeah and
stimulate your brain yeah absolutely
was there a point at which that you you
kind of turned on the interest in
vc-backed companies did something happen
um it was before I even got into YC
funnily enough I went to startup school
2009 and Jason freed was there from
37signals they caught it at the time and
he was like he stood out like a sore
thumb
he was completely different than
everybody else he talked everybody else
is kind of a VC or they are a founder of
a VC back company and he got on stage
and basically said everybody else is
lying to you totally bored they say I
kind of do I see for inviting like a you
know like opposite opinion there but I
was very taken by what he had to say
because no one else was saying it at the
time it didn't really change my approach
at that time but then I got an OIC and
we had the weekly you know Tuesday
dinners or founders of time in the same
thing happened we had a lot of PCs come
in we had a lot of founders of
well-funded companies come in and then
Kevin Hale came in from we foo and he
was like the only person he was kind of
an Andy hacker at the time and he was
just like yeah I packed up my company we
moved to Florida investors' call us
every day we just you know politely say
no and we're just happy making money you
know they're making millions of dollars
a year and I was intrigued by that like
huh hmm but it wasn't until like
recently a basically last year I really
decided that's what I wanted to do for
myself yeah I wasn't really you know and
the mood are really inclined to do the
whole fundraising thing and I'd rather
just make money from an idea online that
I enjoy doing and if that idea was that
indie hackers or was that okay so I mean
the company that I did YC with a task
force still exists it's still out there
it still actually makes money passively
I kind of worked on that for a little
bit
but I didn't think it was really gonna
go anywhere I wasn't enthusiastic three
solid days I wrote about this like 12
years ago or something but a lot of
people when they come to the idea phase
they think that it's something that you
naturally have to be good at you know
you just get a good idea or you don't
right whereas like the reality is it's
like anything other creative endeavor if
you practice for long enough you will
create a good idea you know you don't
try to like paint the Mona Lisa in like
15 minutes and if you don't get it you
give up so I was like all right I'm
gonna push through this I'm gonna spend
like two days coming up with ideas most
of them are absolutely horrible you know
I just deleted them immediately but by
the end of two days I realized I was
consistently coming up with much better
ideas than I had before and I was just
reading through hacker news threads
these people would ask like every month
you know ask hñ what's your profitable
side project or ask AJ and how much
money are you making from your you know
your business and people would share all
the details I figured okay there's like
hundreds of stories here if I read
through enough of them maybe I'll glean
some insights I'll see some patterns
that I can apply it'll help me come up
with an idea hmm and that's literally
exactly what happened I mean the idea of
Randi hackers was based off of the
realization that hey I'm not the only
person who's researching all this stuff
the reason these threads are so popular
is because everybody else is really
interested mm-hmm I could probably do a
better version of these threads and
that's what ID actors is and I was
wondering is it because the because
there's there's been a rise in the
popularity of indie ackers right but I
think there's also a rising in just a
number of those threads all over the
Internet yeah is that because more
people are now thinking about you know
small businesses are just non vc-backed
businesses or there's more people in the
software development space right now I
think it probably a combination so I
read the book sapiens earlier this year
and like my takeaway from it's kind of a
history of all humanity from like the
beginning of evolution
I might take away from sapiens was human
societies tell stories and it's tricky
because it's difficult to determine
whether or not something you believe is
just like an arbitrary story that your
society happens to tell or if it's like
some immutable fact of the universe and
for the longest time like the story
around tech companies has been that like
if you start a tech company you have to
raise a lot of money and prioritize
growth over funding and you know
that's the story so it's amazing how
much everyone just believes that and
doesn't even consider the possibility
that you can start you know a profitable
company that doesn't have to be that big
and you don't need any sort of investors
or gatekeepers to tell you what to do I
think the stories started to change a
lot and once people hear this
alternative version of the story and
once they see examples of it people kind
of like wake up out of the zombie-like
state and like oh I guess I can do that
you know they've sort of been given
permission but there are other practical
factors and reasons why the story has
changed a good one is if I look at the
indie hackers traffic stats something
like 60 percent of the traffic is from
not in the United States let alone
Silicon Valley people are all over the
world starting these companies and it
just from a practical standpoint it's
hard to raise money if you live and like
Bucharest you know it's difficult you
don't live in Silicon Valley you don't
access to investors and so your options
are either you suck it up and try to
raise money locally you move to a tech
hub and raise money there or you just
prioritize profitability which is like
kind of the easiest of those three
options and so I think there's a lot of
just natural pressure as more people
over the world get interested in tech to
start profitable businesses and to care
less about growth over all else hmm and
have you seen that there's there's a
common trend in folks just getting
started like starting similar kinds of
software businesses yeah sure I mean the
other thing is like if you look at the
companies that VCS tend to invest in
they're generally in winner-take-all
markets yeah it's venture capitalist
wants a massive return you really want
to be number one you wanted you know
destroy the competition so it's social
things like Facebook or search you know
applications like Google versus things
that are profitable like you don't want
to be on a winner take a home market
right you don't want to be fighting for
your life every second of the day you
don't want to be you know in a zero-sum
game where everyone else has to lose for
you to win and so people end up starting
businesses that are very related like
how many profitable analytics companies
do you know like email marketing
companies there's a ton mm-hmm you know
how many different ways are there to
teach somebody something I tell people
all the time if you want to start a
business just teach people people like
learning in like a thousand different
ways right some people want to go to
college some people wanted like a
classroom setting some people want to
read some people want video courses some
people want an email newsletters some
people want to learn three games right
like there's no reason why you have to
you know right completely differentiate
from everyone else
you can do something that's similar and
people will like your own unique style
so people for sure start related
businesses and I think it's a good thing
because in it it kind of fosters a sense
of camaraderie you don't have to compete
with everybody you don't have to be
mistrustful of everybody and you can get
advice from people who are similar and
doing things that kind of tread that
path before you well I've been wondering
that with all the guests you get you
know because they're divulging most of
their information right like usually
like how much money they're making all
these kind of metrics are they worried
about copycats or is this something that
now that you have some traction they
kind of like know the deal and it's
easier to get people yeah I mean people
that I've talked to you are generally
not that worried I've had some people
who refuse to come on because they say
what's the benefit of me revealing my
secrets and I'm gonna copy me yeah and
then I've had people who revealed their
secrets that have actually been copied
and it's always hilarious because if you
think about you think about the kind of
person out there he's gonna like just
listen to your podcast at region or
interview that's waiting for someone to
reveal all the details and then they
clone everything that you've done and
like make some like crappy version of
your website but that's you know
different in no way at all except that
it's two years later that's not the most
competent person that you should be
afraid of so I think generally it's a
non-issue especially if you're not in
some sort of winner take all market
mm-hmm okay
even more questions from Twitter there
is a David Adamu asked this question to
both you and Ryan which is part of the
YC application it is tell us about a
time you successfully hacked a non
computer system to your advantage
yeah I do remember doing this on the YC
application my answer now I think would
be more interesting if I related it to
und hackers but early on in any hacker
news history I was kind of running
myself ragged I thought that I mean I
really wanted to put out a lot of
content I wanted to do three or four or
five early on interviews per week and
these are not small interview so like
sometimes a thousand two thousand words
sometimes very poorly written with to
edit and to follow up with the person so
they took hours and hours did the solo
yeah I did it solo and I was sending a
newsletter and I was trying to grow the
business as well and so my trick early
on was like I'm just gonna work 80 hours
a week it was not much of a trick yeah
but eventually I realize like okay this
is not gonna work
you know it's okay to do things that
don't scale but you have to can't do
that forever you need to figure out a
way to make it work and so what I wanted
to do was you know increase or at least
maintain a level the quantity of content
that I was putting out without having
interact on quality and so I wanted to
like the ultimate would be to have some
sort of interview system that like
worked for everyone it was generally
applicable and yet still got interesting
answers and didn't take me very long to
do and the answer that I hit on I kind
of stumbled into it I just started doing
it naturally and it ended up working out
was every time I would do a text base
enter view and I did these interviews
over email
I would ask pretty much the same
questions and then I would look at the
responses and ask follow-up questions
and then I would take a note okay why
did I have to ask a follow-up question
what did they leave out they probably
should have included you know how could
their answer have been better like why
did I go to them and give me a better
answer and after a few months of
interviewing companies from all sorts of
different industries and verticals I had
a gigantic list of ways that people
commonly gave uninteresting interviews
and so I just factored that into my
interview questions so I have like a
question followed by like 10 or 11
bullet points for like here's how you
should answer here's what you should
avoid in your answer here are things
that people like listening to you and so
I started sending that to people and you
know instantly the interviews that I got
back were much more entertaining and
they were required less effort like it's
on the same pack of questions to
everybody hmm so it's kind of a you know
I guess I qualifies as a hack where I no
longer have to do as much work but their
handwriting they're well they're typing
these the answers they're typing the
answer some you every email and every
now and then also a follow-up question
but it was not it was optimized to be as
little work as possible on my part so
that I could do other things like start
the podcast I was selling ads at the
time I took up like half of my time yeah
etc hmm yeah because I found that the
the best hack for me we did a bunch of
interviews with the first employees at
tech companies and the thing that worked
was just doing audio interviews
transcribing them and then doing like
insane amounts of editing because I
found that there were there were just
issues that um you you have trouble
going back and forth to get deeper and
deeper and deeper maybe you figured this
out through repetition but um giving
someone one chance at an answer and then
they like painstakingly like write the
perfect answer
oftentimes it comes out kind of flat
yeah
doesn't work very well no it didn't work
for me early on which is why I had to do
crazy amounts of follow-up emails and I
was just resistant to doing the call
like I didn't want to get on the phone
with people that's why I was so scared
to do a podcast I'm like I want to talk
to people you know I just like the whole
programmer behind the computer type of
my keyboard and that's it yeah it worked
out I mean now we're doing I think when
we launched any hackers last last I when
I launched the last August it was like
10 interviews and took me 3 weeks I sent
hundreds of emails yeah to get 10 people
to agree to an interview and one of them
was me so it's really only 9 people and
now we've got like 200 I think we just
hit 200 this week interviews 30 podcast
episodes
yeah and I'm working you know on that
part of the business less than I ever
had so so what are the other parts
you're working on I'm working on the
community right now okay so any hackers
really it started off as a Content site
really a showcase for these types of
profitable internet businesses but today
it's I would describe it more as a
community of founders and aspiring
entrepreneurs who are like sharing
knowledge of each other and helping each
other to build successful businesses so
the real core of the site is the
community forum it's just a bunch of
people asking each other practical
questions how do i market my site what
do you think about my landing page did I
change this what I think about my idea
you know how do you people find you know
time to work on your projects we have a
family or a full-time job etc and just
helping each other out that takes a lot
of time to grow and I'm thinking about
building like kind of harnessing the
power of the community to build tools
that help these makers and these nd
hackers to actually do better you know
what can what can they all work together
on to to make their lives easier so it
could be something as simple as you know
maybe a crowdsource list of like the
best podcast episodes for this month
just cuz you know I don't want to dig
through all the podcast episodes to find
out what's worth listening to you I want
these other people to tell me or are all
sorts of tools like that I think would
be interesting for this community so I'm
spending almost all my time coding and
talking to people and trying to figure
out what to do there whereas my brother
who was brought on as part of the stripe
acquisition is handling like almost all
of the editing for the interviews and
tour anything with interviewees and
handling like the articles and finding
people to write for indie hackers okay
so that now is just like growth tactics
right to get people into the forum yep
exactly and it's kind of automatic I
mean I'm not doing
many tactical things things get
submitted hacker news I think that's
probably our number one growth channel
people in hacking is reading interviews
which is how the site got launched so
it's not you know particularly nothing
has changed very much in the last year
yeah it's more about like products like
what's the right decision like what's
worth building and what's not it's a
tricky decision because obviously you
know as a one or two person team
building something is a humongous
investment and you don't want to spend
three months building the wrong thing
mm-hmm we have a handful of people
coming up one guy runs a site called
BiggerPockets which I don't have you
seen this before it's basically their
cat giant real estate forum and they've
created tons of educational content and
I think they also have like a bunch of I
might be mistaken that's but a bunch of
like calculators and stuff so basically
these tools that folks who are
interested in real estate investing need
yeah and they've like figured it out
like after someone asked the same
question 400 times and the forum be like
oh maybe there's some amount of interest
here exactly I think that's a cool model
to like when I was scouring how can he
was trying to come up with an idea the
company that I saw then inspired me the
most and actually the first version that
I reached out to you for an interview
afterwards was a company called nomad
list started by this guy Peter levels
who's always on a Chen he's like a you
know crazy personality on Twitter as
well but what he did was basically built
a resource for digital nomads I was
basically a list of all the different
cities in the world and you might want
to travel to you and then just common
stats that you would like to research
like how fast is the internet how safe
is it you know how expensive is it and
so people who are digital nomads are
like of course they want to do this
research they're gonna go to this site
rather than scouring the web and once he
got them all in one place
he built a community and he started
building tools for that community that
are just for digital nomads like himself
yeah I think that's a pretty cool model
it sounds like this real estate sites
the same and he actually I'm very
similar yeah and so because that was a
handful of people on Twitter asked this
question so you know Tom for instance
you know & pratik I'm getting their name
wrong basically how do you how do you
grow for him is the question right like
had you built a forum before no idea I
had no idea I just kind of winged it
I knew I wanted to have a forum so the
day that I launched indie hackers I had
a link on the site that's at forum but
the forum wasn't built yet
and it just had like a sign-up list you
know so we just go to a like a MailChimp
list yeah I'm just getting my MailChimp
listen I wanted to see okay how many
people sign it from the man list on this
page it's some sort of rough indicator
whether or not people want there to be a
forum or a community which I wasn't sure
of you know you could people are already
talking on reddit they're already
talking in hacker news like maybe this
is a big question for a lot of people
they're like why would I build a forum
when I could get discussion you know
even with like my own Facebook group
like what motivated you to do it yeah I
do a lot of things early on that I think
we're a lot of people found unintuitive
they're like why would you do that and
why are you building your own website
rather than using WordPress I wanted to
just use a medium blog you know why
isn't the actors you know this dark blue
website and what's ridiculous you know
why would you do why are you building
your own forum why don't you use
discourse so why don't you just use
Facebook and my thinking from the very
beginning was like your product whatever
you do you should probably take if
you're gonna be invested in it for a
number of years you should take the time
to make it stand out and be different
and be yours and I knew going into it
also that like I'm a computer programmer
the other ideas on my list before I
chose indie hackers were all like kind
of SAS businesses that involved a lot
more development and I regreting Lee
chose the idea that was a blob and the
actors is a blog so I was like okay if
I'm a programmer and I really want to do
these other things but I'm gonna do a
blog I'm gonna allow myself to like do
some fun stuff and make some stuff to
keep myself interested and I also
thought about what I didn't like about
blogs and you know the worst thing about
blogs is when you go to something and
you blog and you read something good on
it and then you come back a month later
you don't even remember that you were
there
yeah there's no way you're gonna go to
Indy hackers and not remember that
you've already been there because it's
quirky dark-blue website that looks like
nothing else on the Internet you know
you might as well stand out so I decided
early on that I didn't want to do you
know the standard thing that other
people were doing I didn't want to you
know use Facebook for my community
groups you know I wanted to do it all
in-house and do it myself
hmm and so if someone were to start a
community like what would be your advice
on getting a forum going okay so number
one I think you need to organize your
forum around a topic that people can
actually talk about and they actually
enjoy talking about it seems obvious but
people do it all the time where they
start a community I think I'm not
something that people don't really like
talking about and then they wonder why
it's empty
like what ah like just like one-off
things like okay let's start a community
about
I don't know it's something super
specific like how do i how do I
incorporate mmm yeah well you can't
really have a community around how do
you incorporate because people ask that
question it's answer then they're out
right so not only do people need to
enjoy talking about it they need to
actually needs to be substantive enough
that they can come back and continue
talking about it yeah starting a
business obviously qualifies because
there's endless challenges right number
two I think you need to have some sort
of strategy to continually drive traffic
to it it can't be you launch your
community on product hunt and then after
that you've got no strategy and this
applies to any product not just a form
with indie hackers if you would if you
were to think about the form is like the
core product of Andy hackers and the
interviews is content marketing I think
that'd be a good model for how it works
so I'm constantly doing these interviews
every week the interviews themselves are
really entertaining approved early on
that people in hacker news and read and
other web sites Twitter enjoy sharing
them so I could do the interviews you
know get people on my mailing list and
then send out links to the community on
my maleness and continually drive
traffic and kind of kickstart it over
and over and over and over again for
weeks mmm so if you if you're starting a
community from scratch and you don't
have any way to consistently drive
traffic to it you're at a tremendous
disadvantage and you're gonna be sort of
just having to pedal faster every single
time you want to get you know more
traffic I didn't have to do that it was
easier because I started with my content
marketing strategy first yeah and I
think finally you got to ensure that
there's good content and discussions
going on early on like I you know the
first week created a bunch of fake
accounts which I heard other people
doing I was like alright this seems
cheesy but you know I'll try it and I
would have conversations with myself
yeah I would have conversations with
other people I never let anyone make a
thread that I didn't respond to you and
try to give them like a valuable
response because otherwise we're not
gonna come back yeah one wants to see an
empty forum know it helps to think of
interesting discussion topics etc so as
long as people like talking about what
you're doing as long as you have a way
to drive traffic there consistently and
as long as you ensure that the
conversations that are interesting I
think over time the forum that you start
will grow so to kind of boil it down
there were no crazy growth like hack
type things it's just you figured out a
market where people are interested in
reading a bunch of content about and
made a bunch of content yeah and then
they just ended up on your site and
following you exactly and like the idea
the crazy growth hacks so overrated yeah
I mean even if I sometimes do an ende
hackers interview people who read it
like on Hacker News will say oh you know
just bore down to this one trick that
this person did and it's like that's
never the case you know I think we all
want it to always be like oh was this
one thing that they did that's
responsible but it's not it's almost
always just like they got the basics
right they made something that people
actually wanted branches like
deceptively simple advice it sounds
simple but people always subtly do other
things that aren't making something that
people want and wonder why no one uses
their product and so the tricks I think
are overrated make sure that you've
built something that people want that's
good and then make sure that you're
actually thinking about how to get
people in the door you're not obsessed
with the product itself right yeah I
mean it's the I mean people call it like
leaky bucket all this stuff it's
continually a piece of advice and when
we're talking about like content or
content marketing with any YC startup
makes something that you're gonna want
to read right you know doing these like
listicles that no one really cares about
and your site looks like medium so no
one remembers what it is I guess it's
kind of just wasting time
I know it's I did the same thing to my
my C company we just slapped a blog on
their website it was so boring we have
announced new features every now and
then it would be empty for like six
months or as I think some of the most
interesting content online is it's it's
treated as if it is the product and e
hackers that content was like the only
thing on the site for months yeah you
know I think you need to put that level
of detail and thought into it and you
know like we were just talking about be
creative to like content doesn't even
have to necessarily look like content
the content on no man list was like a
database of cities with information
about that right that's not like
traditional content but it's interesting
yeah how many how many interviews do you
cut tax interviews with podcast I mean
the answer is it's actually hozier they
all go they all go to print or publish
or whatever I don't think I've ever
conducted a text interview that I didn't
end up putting up you know there might
have been like one or two or someone was
just complete jokester
I get like one sentence responses and I
was like I send it back to them and they
just never responded well I mean that
wasn't me cutting and that wasn't never
responding okay I think a good interview
that you could really coax it out of
anybody if you're willing to like put in
the time and the effort well so that's
the the text thing is what kind of
strikes me
because in person you just like you get
the vibe you're like okay they're gonna
be a little bit difficult but you kind
of like warm up the room in there
they're good when someone's not
responsive over email or not I don't
know not as specific or not as
interesting as you think they could be
how do you get better answers out of
them follow up endlessly until they
either quit or they give you I mean well
we also do sometimes as we'll put there
enter their interview on the site as a
draft which is inline comments like oh
this is a really interesting answer like
here to give us some details besides
what you gave us or like it would be
awesome if you add like a chart or a
graph here in your interview so I think
you know from the outside looking at
maybe it looks like people are magically
just giving good answers but sometimes
you just have to coax them and like you
said like in person you do that by
filling out the room just like you know
vibing off the other person over text
you just take the tedious time to point
out what's wrong and how it can be
better okay
fair enough all right so question from
Tom what was the heart so I mean the
question is what was the hardest with
indie hackers but I think what he means
is what was the hardest thing about
building indie hackers managing my time
early on but I already kind of talked
about that what else was difficult
filling in the hackers I think doing it
alone is a difficult and I'm super lucky
because the site itself a very meta way
is about building startups it's about
starting companies and the way that I
look at it I can my mental model for
building a startup is that essentially
your whole goal it's not to quit I saw
really good tweet the other day that was
here's the secret to success pick any
idea work on it for 10 years
you will succeed just don't quit all
right so the way I look at a startup or
any sort of company is like imagine a
race or marathon where if you get to the
finish line you win you know depending
on how skilled you are and how much you
learn and how good your product is the
finish line might be further away or
closer but all you have to do is keep
running and not quit and I think when
you are a solo founder it's really easy
to quit I mean every time you run into a
hurdle you're like I could quit here you
know I don't know how to get past this
and a lot of people end up putting way
too early just because they're not
prepared for that they think that the
typical startup stories that you just
succeed and you're like yeah
that's from there it's like I've failed
enough time still that's not the case
yeah you don't win by by quitting you
don't win by you know succeeding
overnight you just it's a slog but the
content thing is it's new for you right
like you hadn't done a content thing
before no never right and so content can
feel like a treadmill I mean yeah yeah
it totally feels like a treadmill and I
think that's why I was talking about
earlier it was like having like that
kind of rubric that I sent out it really
helped with that but it never felt like
as long as I got the content like under
control and never felt like I was on a
treadmill I thought okay that's fine I
just need enough time per like every
week to work on pushing the business
forward so I would have you know three
or four days a week to work on
advertising and like that was like a
huge hurdle like I almost quit when I
had no idea how to do ad sales cuz I'm
not a sales person I've never done any
sales before but after like two months
of trying it was like hey I'm pretty
good at this
I'm like sending cold emails to people
and you know getting them on the phone
and like making friends and like people
were buying ads on my website it's
working out same with the podcast you
know like never done it before it ended
up going pretty well but you know back
to what was hard about it I think any
time where I love myself dwell you know
in solitude for way too long it was when
I would think about like this is hard
when I would open up to the community
and send an email saying hey here's what
I'm working on here it's hard and get
support and it suddenly was you know
much easier and to go back to the
marathon analogy you know if you're sort
of running this marathon by yourself and
you look around like no one else is
running of course you're gonna quit if
it's hard right but if like a whole
bunch of other people are running with
you you know then suddenly you're the
social proof of that just helps you
continues it so by kind of you know
forcing yourself to work in public you
could stay motivated exactly that's a
good reason why you know I push people
to be transparent come on the site
you're very little to lose you have a
lot to gain because people will you know
identify with you you'll make friends
people like your personal story they
won't know what's going on behind the
scenes and this whole corporate veel
like always saying we never sharing any
numbers it's just so boring who connects
with that no nobody wants to read that
kind of stuff yeah especially when
you're on your own
and like you know just working at your
little tiny bedroom office exactly yeah
and like unless you live in some sort of
tech hub most people around you like
don't know what you're doing
the Internet's pervasive but like
starting an internet business is still a
pretty rare thing to do and so I think
being able to rely on some sort of
online community whether it's on indie
hackers or another site like if you can
go somewhere and people are also doing
what you're doing and you can tell them
what you're up to you and they can give
you feedback and you know really just
identify with you then you're a much
less likely to quit how do you maintain
a positive community I do
tchau very little actually I was worried
about it because I've been a member of
hacker news for like eight or nine years
I've mixed feelings about it I love it
because the content there is good people
are surface really good links the
discussion is very interesting there's a
lot of smart people in the comments but
it's also super negative I mean the vibe
is who can say the most contrarian
negative thing first that's gonna get
all the outputs there almost everything
that gets submitted so I was worried
about the same thing with indie hackers
especially since so many people from and
the on any hackers came from hacker news
but I think it's naturally a little bit
self policing because these are all
people who were very serious about
building businesses they're people
who've done it before who've perhaps
shared their project on Hacker News or
product end or something and got
negative comments and you know what it
feels like so they're the last people
who were gonna like bash what other
people posts like they're not gonna be
negative [ __ ] cuz they know what it
feels like to be on the other side of it
like they have you know if not the
emotional intelligence at least the
experience to be like oh that sucks you
know maybe I should be careful and just
give positive feedback or like
constructive criticism so I've luckily
not have to be very much at all to
prevent people from from being negative
and I also think the community it's not
it's not a link posting community you
don't go on and the actors and to share
a link to something and say nothing else
you actually have to have a discussion
and so you're actually you know from a
personal perspective saying here's what
I built here's what I did and I think
it's a little bit harder to be an
[ __ ] and the person who wrote you
know the post is also the person who
submitted it yeah I think that's um it D
arms people even on H n when you get
into the thread I advise people this all
the time just like get into the comments
yeah I think people respond much more
positively when they know you're in
there and I really sincerely want to
engage but it's weird they're like oh
this person made it onto the Internet
like what do I do
essica delete account so so someone
asked an interesting question which is
would you advise starting indie hackers
meaning like a person who's getting
started to join an accelerator yes I
would I think okay so I haven't I've
only done YC I can only really vouch for
YC and you know the boring answers
obviously depends on the accelerator if
it's white Tom Nader undoubtedly yes the
advantages outweigh the disadvantages
tenfold and it really goes back to like
you know what is it that kills startups
people quitting mhmmm what do people
very rarely do quit out of an
accelerator well they're surrounded by
other people of doing this and investors
or you're pushing you along so for no
other reason than that I think it makes
sense to join an accelerator but also
like the mentorship that you're gonna
get the advice that you're gonna get I'm
really big on founders running any sort
of community if you can find a way to
position yourself around other people
doing what you what you're doing then
you're gonna increase the chances of
your business succeeding the caveat is
you know usually accelerators come with
like investment terms and investors and
you need to be aware of me to go into
that with both eyes open I spent some
time doing contract work and I worked
for a lot of like VC funded startups for
a few years and it was so interesting
and talking to like the other employees
there sometimes the founders there they
would build like a very good product
that maybe twenty a hundred thousand
people are using people were paying for
and then sometimes just crash and burn
because you know the level of success
they needed to reach in order to meet
their investors expectations was so high
mm-hmm right and so I think if you go
into any sort of accelerator if you
accept money from from investors you
need to be aware that they're not yes
the money might help you you know
succeed and grow faster but at the same
time it's also raising the bar for what
like the minimum bar for success and if
that bar gets raised too high to a
degree that's like unrealistic for your
product to hit if you're building a
to-do list app and you know you need to
be a billion dollar valuation like good
luck there aren't very many bucket to do
list ab c-- now yeah so i think you
should be aware that if you're gonna
join an accelerator yes that is a pro
tip from Silicon Valley it's like know
just know the terms of the deal and know
the expectations it's not crazy but I
think it's one of those themes that
people are really attracted to with
indie hackers because it's this unsaid
like I I don't think VCS are ever trying
to be in the gotcha position because it
doesn't work out for anyone if the
company doesn't work but like when you
set your expectations in life to like
build this billion-dollar company and
you raise the money and then you realize
that you're making it to do a stop
you're not gonna hit that yeah I think a
lot of it is I mean like I said earlier
people just like hear one story you know
they don't they don't really think about
what what kind of deal they're making or
why they're knowing that route or why
they've you know why they feel the need
to build a billion-dollar company and
you know I agree with you as well like
the VCS aren't like super nefarious and
like I want to trick everyone right but
at the same time like their incentives
are such that you know 90% of the time
they would rather have a whole bunch of
people fail and a few people will make
it big and have everybody have kind of a
middling result right and so if you're a
founder you have to ask yourself you
know do I want to have a high risk of
failure to have that one shot at the top
or do I want to you know maybe make 10
or 20 thousand dollars a month or you
know a small exit or something and then
maybe go for the big shot I think is
probably the more rational decision for
most people
I would imagine so yeah all right so
there's another question from Burt
are there other recipes for folks
growing a side hustle or you know small
business whatever you want to call it in
Europe compared to the US I don't think
so the reason is because if you compare
you know it's working on a side hustle
to you know building more of like a
high-growth startup if you're trying to
like hit a billion dollar valuation what
you care about you care about really
what you need is like a this potent
confluence of factors all pushing in the
same direction like you need the best
idea ever you need the best team ever
you need like a growing market that for
some reason has like no real competitors
are a bunch of bumbling competitors you
need the best investors the most money a
little bit of luck you need everything
like to help you whereas if you're
building a side hustle if you're
building a smaller business that like
still might be life-changing but it's
like you know it doesn't need like all
the luck in the world and every factor
to line up then really all you need to
like just some solid business
fundamentals it's definitely learn about
and those are gonna be the same no
matter where you are whether you're in
Europe or the u.s. like you still need
to build something that people want you
still need to have some sort of market
in distribution strategy you still need
to be able to manage your time and like
not run out of money etc that doesn't
change from place to place
the only thing that really changes is
you know the number of people in the
community who understand what you're
doing your access to capital if you want
to raise money you know legal things and
then taxes but everywhere I've been I
mean I went to South Africa I talked to
some many hackers there you're building
a business for the internet you know
your customers are everywhere they're
not it doesn't matter where you live
yeah are you only interviewing SAS
companies no I energy the most random
variety of companies I tried early on
did have like some sort of rubric and
generally if somebody emails me in the
like hey I've got a consultancy you know
like I tried it I guess and you know
it's not the best fit because you're
really just trading dollars for hours
however I think SAS companies are kind
of the most interesting okay you know
they have their kind of the dream but
people who want passive income and
people who want like the freedom that
come to that lifestyle but there's
lessons to be learned from other
companies too
a good one is Scotch cheap flights who
did one of the coolest tech Center views
on indie hackers it's basically this guy
Scott who found like super cheap flights
for himself and all of his friends were
like hey I want cheap flights to like
how did you how did you go round trip to
whatever it's like this diagram of like
nerds and like airline hacking things
like you wouldn't believe how many YC
applications like we're gonna blow your
mind with this new mileage plan people
really like saving money on flights and
yeah and it's it's a little insane like
people will spend way more money saving
money on like time saving money on
flights and they could like earn if they
just like what yes yeah but anyway Scott
like was super good at it he built this
email list of you know his friends and
colleagues really he was just sending
the flight deals and he was finding for
himself and it turned from like that
tiny side project until like this
massive business that's doing like 4
million dollars a year it's not SAS at
all it's it's Scott and his friends now
and the people who's hired scouring the
internet and manual is it there's no but
there's no - no there's I mean that's
that's it and people pay to be part of
this mailing list like they pay to be
like frequently sent cheap flights so
they can go it's really worth it for
them so that's not a SAS company one of
the coolest interviews ever and again
it's like all the same business
fundamentals make something people want
right he had to find a way to actually
advertise his mailing list and get
people on it
you know his marketing site is so psych
it's super slick super streamlined like
the conversion rates are extremely high
super transparent about everything you
know like and it makes his emails fun
because it's like hey it's got here
cause he's getting an email from a
person that you know who's trying to
help you out that is really cool
you spoke of a the the Nomad list guy
before were there other role models for
you when your because I completely agree
it's so important
we're having a Pete Adney mister money
mustache yeah on the podcast oh cool and
he's awesome but I think his his whole
deal was so influential anymore in that
he's just like software engineer for 10
years saved up like six or seven hundred
K was like about yeah I like index fun
rely on the income from that but I think
he's just another example of just
showing people the way were there other
people that were kind of like showing
you the way yeah David hi Tamara Hanson
from from base camp was a big one and
Jason freed so I went to startup school
on nine and saw Jason free talk but my
favorite talk was DHHS talk the year
before he was just like it was super
entertaining if you haven't seen it you
should watch it but he completely just
like just everybody there and he was
just like saying common sense things
like you know you can build a business
and telling people things they hadn't
heard before so whenever I felt below I
would I would watch I price and that
talk like 50 times just cuz it's so
inspirational that one it's a really
good one who else I think you know Peter
levels that was a big one I mentioned I
didn't have that many influences I you
know I when I was reading through the
hacker news threads to find examples I
found a lot of really cool examples and
people always like oh you know what
they're doing is awesome that inspired
me to know that it was possible and keep
going but there isn't any one person
what about the just the idea of making a
Content site was that like you were
reading some because HN is an aggregator
right so was there one site that stood
out like oh this is cool no I mean I
think this is a big thing I tell people
all the time like your product you
shouldn't start by thinking about what
your product is gonna be and then and
then you know making that we you should
start is by figuring out what people
want and then based on what people want
you find the best possible way to give
them that when people want it in the
situation which there's really two
things they wanted to do what I was
doing and like have some sort of easy
way to research ideas for products and
number two like I think people just
found it entertaining to read these
stories
and so like the conclusion I came to you
after seeing that was like okay what
people if I want to really want to
provide what people want it's gonna be
some sort of content site right
whether it's interviews whether it's a
podcast whether it's videos is like
completely up in the air like all of
those are valid solutions to that
problem but like you know I for sure
need to include some transparent revenue
stats right just for sure need to get
some like behind-the-scenes details like
there are things that if I really wanted
to get people what they wanted or like
you know absolutely required and so I
made sure to just do those things but
like I said like I was I'm a developer
like starting a content sites not it's
so boring to me and I was so upset that
that was the best idea that they came up
with but I was also excited about it is
the back end of the site user-friendly
at all are you like publishing from the
terminal it's not you it's not user
friendly at all it was like the whole
bus factor I'll get you if you get hit
by a bus you know how can can you know
your products stay in that can someone
else come in and the indie hackers yeah
I know yeah I'm just I just I look both
ways when I cross the street
exactly yeah we're WordPress now for
that exact reason all right are there
common failures with a lot of these a
lot of these indie hacker founders that
they they describe us you know like
maybe something in the early days that
they struggled with and that that's
common between many of them yeah you
hear the stats all the time like you
know 90% of businesses fail yeah but I
think like the earlier and earlier you
go and the funnel the more failures you
see like the ultimate like top of the
funnel most failures are sees as people
who are interested in starting a
business but never get started not for
lack of motivation or care but because
they don't know what the first step is
right are they are mostly misinformed
about what the first step is so they for
example like I said earlier spend five
or ten minutes thinking up an idea every
now and then it doesn't come to them and
they conclude that they're just not you
know they just can't do it or it's like
actually you should probably dedicate
like three or four days at with an idea
because it's this inflection point
that's going to control the next few
years of your life you know and it's not
easy to come up with one off the top of
your ad so people will get kind of
frustrated by that and stop or they
won't be able to figure out the legal
situation or early on and so they'll
stop which is why stripe has atlas for
example to help people out with that and
make it super easy
you know not not having traction in the
early days super frustrating the people
and they quit so consistently I mean I
sound like a broken record here but it's
like you know the more times I say it
hopefully the more will sink in people
quit
way too early way before they should
quit you know like your your idea some
people think their ideas are terrible
guys my deal is so flawed I'll type in a
video like that's a great idea
you just have to actually execute on it
I think that hurts the other thing is I
think people don't read enough and I I
get the opposite of this often I hear
people say oh stop reading and just
start doing that's true but I think if
you're the kind of person who is going
to have the determination and the grit
like actually start a succesful
successful startup then you're probably
not going to like quit because you spent
too much time reading up front like
that's not gonna be what stops you for
that type of person
but the benefits are meaning they're
like massive because starting a startup
is not intuitive
it was intuitive and there wouldn't be
so many guides and books to doing it
everything you did that felt right would
just work yeah right but any time you
see an industry that's populated with
intelligent people and yet most of them
are still failing it's probably worth
taking a step like a step back to say
like there's something going on here
that people don't you know realize and I
should read and learn from other
people's mistakes instead of repeating
their mistakes and learning from my own
horrible experiences and that's not to
say that experience is not a good yeah
so what do you tell someone when they're
like okay I'm in like I'm subscribed to
your like workout plan I'm gonna spend
four days and get my idea mm-hm
what are you tell them to read I tell
them to read the indie hackers
interviews which are just a better
version of the same age and posts that I
was reading though I tell them to post
on the forum share what you're doing
right don't go into a black hole and
then you know emerge two months later
and do that guy never did find an idea
why don't you just keep a list of what
you were saying coming up with and post
them on the forum and people are happy
to tell you what they think well used to
do next etc and I think there's this
kind of overwhelming assumption that
we're just alone and that you can't
share because there's not that many
communities where people do this I mean
I get it it's not a common thing you
just aren't used to it so I'm trying to
reverse that someone on the indie
hackers forum said earlier that they
wouldn't like it if I made the forum a
little bit more structured and they
created a specific way to ask her
feedback because he felt spammy
like I don't like spamming people and
asking like that's the entire point of
this forum is for you to ask these
questions and it feels smadi's uh yeah I
think I've underestimated a little bit
how much it can be scary or feel like
not just not normal to ask people for
like transparent advice on what's going
on but that's my advice to people you
know as long as you have mentors and
people who know what they're talking
about who can help you out and as long
as you don't quit you know then even if
you do things wrong you're gonna get
some good advice and you'll be able to
correct hmm okay were there any books
that guided you I love like all the most
popular stuff that books from Lean
Startup is great about Erik Ruiz I like
crossing the chasm it's a little bit
older it was like the kind of a Lean
Startup of the 90s I think but still
great advice there and then talks about
you know the early adopters and all the
way through like the mainstream and late
adopters and the difference between
appealing to those different segments
which i think is extremely important for
people to know I like Peter Thiel's zero
to one I think the thing that trips a
lot of people up while I'm talking about
these books is that not every book is
gonna tell you who it's written for if
you read zero to one that book is
written for like high-growth startups
it's got a lot of advice in there that's
terrible if you're trying to you're
trying to bootstrap your way to success
and so people will come in and they'll
say you know like right I did this thing
and it's not working why isn't working
because that's advice that's like does
not apply to you but I think if you're
careful and you understand okay who was
just reading for and what you know
nuggets can I take away then almost all
these books have some some negative
advice that's useful
hooked by nearly all really cool book
talks all about the psychology of
habit-forming products and like what
people look at people coming back why
don't we form how i've habits etc
totally unaware of that until I had them
in my podcast and I read the book and
Ryan Hoover helped like edit it as well
that's probably my product time is so
addictive yeah but a really cool book
definitely worth a read for everybody
and also books outside of the startup
echo chamber I have so many people who
say
Cortland I've got this idea for a you
know an app that will let you like place
an order at your local coffee shop
before you get there and it's like I
hear this idea like seven times a week
and the reason is because everybody's
reading the exact same books and the
exact same blog posts and living in the
exact same place and so if you all the
same inputs you're gonna have like the
same
ideas as everybody else totally so like
if you really want to come up with
something creative like not only should
you invest the time to think about it
but like travel you know go visit a
different culture read some fiction or
sci-fi or something like to get your
creative juices flowing don't only read
startup books yeah I think you have to
have an opinion
outside of the norm you do because it's
true like yeah just hang out here long
enough and it's the same ideas exactly
yeah
do any of the so this is a camera
Reynold s'en how often do you see indie
hacker projects transitioned from
lifestyle businesses to startups or do
they ever yeah all the time
I mean Scott she fights great example
totally okay so it depends on your
definition of lifestyle business if you
mean lifestyle this is any business that
makes money and a start-up is someone
who's raised a lot of money from venture
capitalists actually don't see that very
often
very rarely does somebody who is killing
it and making millions of dollars
decides they can erase a ton of capital
mm I think most of those cases are
pretty famous mm-hmm
but I see the opposite actually often
which is companies will raise one round
and then they won't raise any more money
okay we're killing it we don't need to
raise any more money we understand like
what level our investors expect us to
get to you we're comfortable with that
zapier is a good example
I had wait on the podcast he they're
doing extremely well I just need to
raise any money
Kevin hey aloof who did the same thing
back in the day and I also see a lot of
like side projects that start off is you
know I just want to supplement my income
and make a few thousand bucks a month
that turn into I'm quitting my job this
is it full-time this guy Mike param
that's you created an app called
sidekick it's basically like a
background job processor for developers
so that they can run tasks in the
background on their server and make
their websites faster he was doing it on
the side of his business but he was kind
of mixing it with this business and then
he quit his job and was like I'm not
gonna work my full-time job anymore this
is like taking off right and that's kind
of a dream because now he's got the
freedom to work on whatever he wants
from wherever he wants for whatever
hours he wants and like there's no
upside on his income he's making
something like a million something
dollars a year as a solo developer just
doing what he likes
there you go not a typical story like
not everybody makes a million dollars a
year but that definitely went from like
side-project and hobby into like more
than a
that's a real struggle like I know a
bunch of software developers that have
they're like you know cushy Internet job
and have a side thing and they struggle
to figure out like at what point do you
really switch yeah
like is that a and is there like an
advice section in the forum that people
like struggle with this question or is
this actually more rare yeah oh it's
very common any hackers as it exists
right now it's not very prescriptive
like it's not organized into you an
answer to every specific question you
might have it's more free-flowing and so
every now and then a topic might pop up
about that and people will get all sorts
of good responses but my personal advice
would be it really depends on the level
of risk that you want and it's harder
once your developer or even a non
developer and some job or it's cushy and
making money like when I first moved out
here I was the stereotypical like you
know 22 year old eating ramen noodles
like I didn't care what kind of
apartment I lived in yeah and then I
started shopping at Whole Foods and you
know got a better apartment yeah now
it's like okay I can't I can't quit my
job or you know do something less I have
a really good idea that's really working
out and I under M pyth I have people who
are in that situation I really think
that you should have some sort of
product market fit like you should be
confident that your product can work
right if you've launched a side project
and there's no one's using it yet and
you're just excited to code on it
that's probably premature for you to
leave your job right get every software
engineer really likes coding on their
own thing it's fun but you really need
to get to the point where you've found a
way that to get people to your app and
you found a way that you know to
actually grow your revenue and you can
say okay at this rate it's a matter of
time
I think that's helpful and I realize
that it's kind of intimidating if you're
not if you're if you're not a person who
would describe yourself as like a
business person right if you're like I
write code I have no idea what like what
did it means to do business well he's
really there's no such thing right it's
just a collection of individual tasks
like finding people to come to your app
right which is if you read enough
examples like you'll start to see the
patterns you'll start to see what
options are available to you and so I
would encourage people not to be worried
that they don't have experience here
just make sure to read and learn from
what other people are doing make sure
that you are persistent and you don't
quit at the first sign of distress and
then you know if things start working
it'll be pretty obvious with my parent
it was like hey
making 50k a year from my app 100k a
year now it's only been two months or
you know with Scott with Scott she
fights it's like you know suddenly I'm
making like thousands of dollars I can
hire somebody you know why do I need to
work my job yeah also like the if you're
a talented developer the downsides
pretty low right you know ideally it
makes enough money to sustain you you
spend six months on it and if it doesn't
work out you can get another jockey I
mean that's what I did I was contracting
I quit and I had enough savings to live
for like a year or two in San Francisco
which could have got me much further in
any other city like I do not recommend
trying to bootstrap in San Francisco
paying ridiculous rent here
but ultimately it's like okay I'm
confident that if things don't go well
like I'll have a back-up plan it's much
harder if you're in a different
situation yeah for sure
how are things going now that you're at
stripe awesome they're not watching
stripe was a great company it's it's so
funny because acquisition happened
completely out of the blue yeah that's
like oh how did you set up the
acquisition blah blah blah like I
started a blog you know one starts a
blog to uh to get acquired you know like
the anvil company email came completely
out of the blue from Patrick but it's
really the perfect union
like I think some people you know every
nine won't be skeptical especially in
hacker news about any sort of
acquisition like I mean you know what's
the real play here I think it was
obviously good for me it's good for
stripe it's good for the indie actors
community for nd hackers to be under
stripe yes definitely if you look at
like stripes goals and incentives here I
mean Patrick Collison came in on the
hacker news thread that announced
acquisition and made the top comment we
just said flat out here's why we're
requiring indie hackers it was super
straight forward which is stripe does
better if more people are starting
companies and those companies are more
successful and the hackers his mission
is to help more people start companies
and be more successful mmm there's no
you know there's no man behind the
curtain there there's no sort of secret
thing going on you know and also just
examining like a world know nd hackers
without stripe versus nd hackers at
stripe so what I was doing you know back
in February March is spending an
inordinate amount of my time finding
advertisers putting ads in my newsletter
putting ads on the website putting ads
on the forum ads you know as much as
they might fund a site they don't make a
site wet like there may
better now what is happy to get a
newsletter that's got to add tonight it
doesn't help anyone right it didn't help
me to do anything other than pick up the
ability to do like home sales yeah and
pay rent right but ultimately at stripe
I guess salary I don't have to worry
about paying rent you know I'm not like
worried and the hackers gonna go under
they're not going to shut the website
down they didn't not buy it to shut it
down they did not buy it for to become
some super profitable thing in the next
like six months or anything so the long
term is pretty much set and now I can
just focus 100% on my original mission
which is just helping people start
companies and showing that there's
another way to do it that's not you know
the story that we've all heard mm-hmm
so stripes wouldn't super fun they're
really hands-off I think I've met with
Patrick like three times since I've
joined in like the last six months and
he's super smart dots I can just
brainstorm together and think about how
to make the site impactful so it's
really the perfect acquire and the
incentives are aligned perfectly but
there's nothing that I want to do that
they don't also want to do that's great
do you have any side projects going on
right now no okay if you could start any
side project which one would you be Jeff
would I start
it's so fun on me it's gonna be a coin
it needs to be it would be like oh
they'll be hackers Ike oh really I don't
know actually you know that I think I
would I would my side project would be I
would follow the same formula I followed
last time I need to spend four days get
my brain into that mode where it's
actually good at this yeah it's like
riding a bicycle if you haven't written
a while and you're gonna suck but after
you pedal for a while you get good
coming up an idea you need to take the
time to do it that being said I think if
you run a business for a while you start
to see like opportunities for things
where if that existed you would pay for
it for sure
you know like I'm trying to manage my
Twitter account it's just a hassle to do
that and also do all the other things
like I really want like better tools for
social media a lot of tools also media
already exists and a lot of them are
wildly popular
mmm profitable so I've got some ideas in
that area and and it's hard to say but I
think maybe the day will come where I
work on a side project on the side of
indie hackers we'll see I've way too
much to do now yeah a lot of the stuff
that I'm doing for any actors like
there's almost side-project ish you know
like my life hasn't changed very much at
all and I'm still working at home many
hackers after also like on schedule yeah
exactly
so it's not it's not too different cool
all right and
many more questions cool yeah it was fun
you